hi guys I want to do a video on ketosis
after cheat day well first of all I want
to know whoever said you could actually
cheat on the program anyway I don't know
who made that up
I mean ketosis after cheat day is very
is equivalent to marriage after a cheat
day you might end up with some problems
right because what happens is it took
you 2 to 6 weeks to get into ketosis
because your cells have to adapt your
enzymes have to adapt and you're going
along and all of a sudden you have a
cheat day well you think you can just
like a switch and pop it right back well
if it took two weeks to get into ketosis
how many how much time you think it's
gonna take to get back into it after you
cheat it could take anywhere between 48
to 72 hours if you're lucky
but sometimes up to a week yeah I'm
sorry to tell you that and so there's
some variables I want to talk about if
you're 23 years old and you're a guy and
you're fairly thin you could probably
flip back and forth with no problem but
if you're 50 or 60 year old female that
has been and diets it's gonna be a
situation because the metabolism is
still not repaired so in other words if
you cheat just realize it's gonna take a
long time to get you back into where you
started from
now sometimes people will when I
evaluate them I find out they haven't
gone back to the original eating plan
it's somewhat of a modified ketogenic
diet where their each day they're eating
a little bit of the wrong food well
they'll never get back into ketogenic
ketosis because the whole hallmark of
ketosis is low carbs really low carbs ok
so the variables are metabolism so
that's gonna predict how fast you can
get back into ketosis if your metabolism
is good you could probably get back to
and fast also your age that's important
not how long you've been in ketosis if
you've done this for several years your
system is finally efficient where you
could probably switch back and do it
pretty easy but if you've done this you
started last month and you you lived
your whole life on sugar it could bump
you way out of ketosis and I keep
getting this question you know I had my
cheat day and it's I'm not back into
ketosis and it's been
week I said well you're not quite there
yet so and I don't know who gave you
authorization to cheat anyway but I
never did so and then how well you're
sticking to ketosis when you're doing it
and then how much you cheat so if you're
cheating the whole day versus let's say
one meal that could be a variable as
well so I just wanted to point out that
I think your cheat should be a healthy
pleasure food that you can actually make
with these recipes I'll put some links
below like you have the keto bombs you
can do with chocolate you can do with
almond flour and really enjoy that but
if you're gonna just car about that
could be a problem and just have the
expectation that it's going to take some
time to get back alright thanks for
watching